wir haben jetzt noch mal den ganzen song
von vorne an
[Musik]
doch gar nicht gibt
ein hund da würde ich mal gespannt ich
war gestern abend nach längerer zeit mal
wieder so intensiver youtube unterwegs
habe ich ein bisschen umgeschaut und
natürlich habe ich schon mal so am rande
mitbekommen das kann ich ja vor hat auch
in eigenen song rauszubringen finde ich
auch eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht
ich meine auf youtube geht es um
unterhaltung mit dem stück wieder
lustiger sorgen gibt viele displays gibt
vielleicht auch ein paar lustige
kommentare warum nicht also dass das
jetzt nicht die beste musik wird ich
denke das wissen wir alle aber ich freue
mich natürlich trassen drauf und ich
glaube das kommt jetzt irgendwann diese
woche öffnen und so keine ahnung aber
bevor wir das von rauskommt am ersten
idee gekommen
juli wusste ja dann schon wieder keine
ahnung wo der grat ist auf jeden fall
ist juni dj also er macht viel mit musik
und ich bin zwar recht gut er hat da
wirklich talent ich kann mich auch mal
ein link in die infobox packen zu seinem
sound raver count oder sonst was ich
habe es auf jeden fall vorher mich immer
für meinen laptop zu setzen
walter ich bin gerade einfach
aufgestanden und dann ist der stuhl hoch
gegangen mein fuß runter und ich habe
mich drauf gesetzt genau mein kleiner
zeh auf jeden fall bevor der richtige
katastrophe aus kommt werden wir jetzt
unseren eigenen kassen machen mit die
aussagen also ich suche jetzt witzige
zitate von katja rausschneiden
hintereinander und die gebe ich dann
gleich juli wenn er mal wieder da ist
und dann machen wir daraus man richtig
geilen song also leute gebt ihm eine
halbe stunde und ich bin mal gespannt
was ich als kind werde diese video
titeln also ich bin echt fast nie auf
ihrem channel so aber wenn man nur drauf
ist so bläst man richtig groß heißt es
privat wie du von mir
1,1 millionen klicks wisst ihr was mir
dazu einfällt
ich glaube das ist ihr erfolgreichstes
video irgendwie da macht sie so eine
katze sondern sein
okay leute ich habe jetzt warte
insgesamt bestimmt so zehn zitate
gefunden die echt witzig sind das ganze
geht eine halbe minute sogar habe ich
weiß nicht ob wir alles nehmen können
aber ich spüre ich das jetzt einfach mal
so ab wie ich es jetzt hier in thailand
dargelegt habe natürlich wird das noch
anders angeordnet und ich weiß natürlich
nicht genau wie sich am ende anhören
wird
aber das ist das was ich so am
witzigsten fand aus fünf sechs sieben
acht neun zehn videos können
also ich war auch nie aber wenn ich
wirklich so ist er nicht wirklich irgend
text will dann mache ich halt das
argument zurück ich lese gerne mein
größter sieg auf der brust ich wäre ja
merkwürdig
ich habe versucht was sie meinen namen
sagt ich habe neben bundesstelle
gefunden wo sie halt alex sagt als
wirklichen namen deswegen musste ich das
aus alle und sex zusammenschneiden
und ja da haben wir als im moment also
leute also es ist schwer zu verstehen
glaube ich wenn man es nicht weiß aber
wenn man es weiß sondern hört und das
haben wir auch noch was hast du gehört
ja leute wird bestimmt witzig wir müssen
jetzt erstmal dem die uni lernen dann
kann ja unsere kunden teil irgendeinen
quatsch machen so leute die juli ist
jetzt auch am start und meinte du machst
einen super song daraus also ich hab
echt die herzlichsten zitate gefunden
und guckt euch mal eine viel zusammen
egal wir gehen jetzt lernen und heute
abend schauen wir einmal was soll ich
denn echt nur bei juni kommen und heute
abend schauen wir dann mal was wir draus
machen können bzw
da hinten die leute was geht wir haben
jetzt mittlerweile schon den nächsten
tag eigentlich wollten wir das gestern
abend noch machen haben es aber nicht
geschafft dann hat er mir versprochen
dass wir es halt jetzt heute morgen
machen das problem ist nur ich habe
jetzt gleich eine halbe stunde
friseurtermin und von juli habe ich
heute noch kein lebenszeichen gemacht
deswegen habe ich jetzt folgendes
geplant ich ziehe einfach diese
ausschnitte auf eine sd karte legt die
jugend vor die tür
und wenn er aufsteht kann er vielleicht
anfangen ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt
und wir sehen uns dann gleich genau hier
wieder nicht meine neuen haare also das
sind jetzt meine neuen haare sind
irgendwie ein bisschen grau und gesagt
hier vorne aber so finde ich eigentlich
auch cool so leute und ich bin jetzt
halt wieder hier juli ist mittlerweile
auch unter uns und er hat auch schon
angefangen
manchmal nur die eine stelle da mit
[Applaus]
mega cool also erst mal gespannt wie
sich das anhört wenn es also ganz fertig
ist und dann stehen wir das mal nicht
legal als nächstes jahr dann spielen wir
das mal richtig über die boxen
wohnzimmer ich meine ich wie lange
brauchst du noch das habt ihr müsst die
scheint aber jetzt guck mal ich muss
diese eisernen spuren alle wahr was
machen wir noch vielleicht alex reid
irgendwo vielleicht in das gap schon
fast schon okay doch ich mache jetzt
erstmal weiter und weil sonst gleich was
ist es voll besteuert auch hier leute
mussten gerade noch mal kurz hier
irgendwas lauter machen wir haben es
doch mal den ganzen song von vorne an
[Musik]
verstehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein beispiel
[Applaus]
schaltungen iis mit
[Musik]
auf jeden fall eure meinung sollte die
kommentare
[Musik]
ich sage dazu wieder verliert ich frage
auch nie aber wenn es wirklich so ist ja
nicht wirklich und sexuellen machen
ich hab keinen der den platz
ich glaube zum video für
ich nehme mich da
die banken
die schwer
[Musik]
und ich erhalte
wir sind sehr kranker song ich bin
gespannt wie sehr dieser song im
original gleichen wird leute wir uns
eigentlich überlegt dazu auch so ein
kleines musikvideo zu machen nur
vielleicht machen wir das dann in
separaten video nicht zu ihr gerne nackt
genau ich würde sagen wenn ihr darauf
bock habt wie vielleicht war wird das
muss schon sprechen dicke 15.000 15.000
15 tage gibt's das muss ich wieder zu
unserem katja so schlecht doch auf jeden
fall leoni vorbei ich habe schon anfang
gesagt bei deinem songbird profil
das hat er wieder beschreibung verlinkt
jackson dacia duster gemacht und wir
sehen uns ein vorteil dass wir sehen uns
zu verabschieden
wir sind uns freitag wieder weiter gibt
es ein neues video partei